Happen.
The Joe Rogan experience,
they do that world,
don't forget.
Right.
Ilan could talk all the shit he wants.
I remember he had a McLaren f one yes he did.
And he still has a Jaguar e type one of those really old ones.
Like a 69 with the wrong sharp.
No Long Hood.
Yeah.
He's still,
he had malaria so he at heart,
he knows the deal.
You know what I mean?
But he didn't make that car that fast for a practicality.
No,
it makes no sense.
The same reason he made a fucking blow torch.
Exactly right.
It's a silly person.
He's just not a flame thrower.
We know that.
It's not definitely,
definitely silly.
Super Genius.
So it is,
what do you think and all the best ways.
Yes.
Right.
Only good ways.
I never say anything bad about him,
of the guy.
He's glad he's alive.
I am.
I'm glad he's a real thing.
No,
honestly I and I hose and degree.
I get a lot of crap from people online saying like,
I'm an Eli moss cater.
I'm a Tesla hater.
I could be critical sometimes.
You know what I mean?
But it's like the guys of the cousin damn genius.
He's a damn genius.
Damn genius.
And critical is important,
guys.
Like you are important.
It's very important to hear what other people think.
If it's rezoned in intelligent,
right.
I can help you even if you don't like hearing it.
All right.
So I've got to keep,
I mean,
he's a genius,
but sometimes you gotta keep the company in check.
The cars are phenomenal cars.
They're phenomenal cars and they weren't always,
no,
absolutely not.
Yeah.
And what they were,
when they first came out,
like,
dude,
are you aware of the whole thing with top gear?
Yes.
That was crazy.
Yeah,
they were being shady.
we're super shady.
Yeah.
They were running the car down.
The car died.
They wanted to bash the car,
but they could.
But like for stuff like that,
like I'll stick up and say,
Yo,
hey,
you can't keep doing that.
And he got pissed.
He loves it.
That's his baby.
Yeah.
He sues the baby.
I think he lost because I think the way there's show is structured that was,
it's entertainment,
it's entertainment.
It's incredibly damaging to the company because it made it look like,
I don't know why they did that.
There's a couple of things that they did the top gear did,
but I was like,
why would you do that?
Right.
That was the sound of,
some people remember they,
their,
their focuses on petrol or gas powered cars.
Like when a,
when an eevee comes along and it's actually pretty damn good,
and a lot of cases,
people are just like,
shit,
and like,
you can't let this thing win.
Especially back back in the day when that was going on.
Right.
And that was a long time ago.
That was in 2012 I think.
Yeah.
2013 yeah.